[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
magazine européen de la rédaction de tv
78e 7,8 europe je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce numéro du mois de
novembre
et si une partie de l'avenir du tourisme
franciliens et et fluviales c'est dans
ce sens en tout cas que travail
l'association val de marne tourisme et
loisirs en partenariat avec d'autres
villes européennes elle réfléchit à
travers le projet star cities à
développer le patrimoine culturel et
naturel des zones fluviales et pour
réussir sa mission l'association
bénéficient des fonds structurels
européens
que s'est-il passé ce mois ci dans
l'union européenne l'actualité
européenne en brèves avec la commission
européenne qui multiplie les command
pour le futur vaccin contre la copie de
19 des tensions entre parlement et états
membres autour du budget dit de relance
ou encore des élus inquiet pour l'avenir
du parlement européen situé à strasbourg
ils n'ont plus qu'un mois pour éviter le
node îles britanniques et européens
poursuivent leurs négociations marathon
en vue d'établir une nouvelle relation
entre les deux parties plusieurs points
achoppent encore risque-t-on vraiment le
no deal nous ferons le point sur le
sujet avec emmanuel saulnier cassia
spécialiste du sujet et enseignante à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
[Musique]
comment assurer un tourisme plus
respectueux de l'environnement cette
problématique est au coeur des
préoccupations des lieux touristiques
depuis plusieurs années déjà en
ile-de-france l'association val de marne
tourisme et loisirs pilote à un projet
européen sur le sujet il se nomme star
cities et celui ci vise à développer le
tourisme fluvial en coopération avec
d'autres territoires européens pour y
parvenir échanges et rencontres sont
organisées depuis paris et dans d'autres
villes européennes précisions et
explications de camille showa est
chargée de mission pour val de marne
tourisme et loisirs c'est un projet qui
rassemble sept partenaires européens qui
souhaitent développer le tourisme
pluviales au bord et sur l'eau donc
c'est pour cette raison qu'on ait
aujourd'hui à champigny sur marne
puisque donc notre objectif à travers ce
projet c'est vraiment de valoriser et de
développer le tourisme sur les bords de
marne a donc on travaille avec plusieurs
villes européennes donc hambourg en
allemagne
cahoon a c'est en lituanie la ville de
rome en italie et lubiana en slovénie et
donc avec ses partenaires là et le
réseau next ou requis et le réseau qui
rassemble les régions européennes pour
un tourisme durable et compétitif on se
rencontre donc on a un programme des
chants sur trois ans avec des séminaires
thématiques sur lesquelles on va
échanger les bonnes pratiques et des
expériences de chacun sur le tourisme
fluvial
au départ du projet dont nous nous
sommes le pilote dans le val de marne
tourisme et loisirs on a souhaité
rassembler autour de nous d'autres
villes européennes en se disant que
équivalente des bords de marne on va
dire dans différentes villes européennes
avait une carte à jouer pour le tourisme
de demain parce que c'est des lieux qui
propose un tourisme durable proche de
l'environnement authentique qui permet
aussi de rencontrer des habitants et
c'est donc vraiment quelque chose de
très authentique et très complémentaires
aussi de la visite beaucoup plus
classique des villes qu'on peut faire
avec les grands sites du centre-ville
donc un des principaux objectifs c'est
aussi de déconcentrer finalement les
plus touristiques des centres de ces
grandes villes européennes vers les
périphéries en utilisant les cours d'eau
comme un vecteur finalement pour faire
venir des visiteurs qu'ils soient
régionaux et nationaux ou internationaux
évidemment sur des territoires qui ôte
dans lesquelles ils ne vont pas
habituellement lorsqu'ils vont visiter
ces grandes capitales donc donc c'est
vraiment un tourisme durable authentique
et qui valorise évidemment aussi le
patrimoine et l'histoire qui est souvent
très riches de ces territoires là
le projet se déroule en deux phases la
première phase c'est celle axel dans
laquelle nous sommes donc c'est la phase
d'échangé d'expérience donc le principe
c'est très simple c'est que on va chez
chaque partenaire chez chaque dans
chaque région pour faire un séminaire de
travail dans lequel on va faire des
visites de terrain rencontrer les
partenaires du territoire
qui nous accueille est rentré finalement
découvrir les projets les plus
intéressants que mène ce territoire là
évidemment ce programme a été un peu
remis en question par la crise sanitaire
puisque la crise est arrivée juste avant
qu on comprit suivent ces séminaires en
sur place et donc on peut pas se
déplacer aujourd'hui donc on est en
train de grossir voir pas mal notre
courant qui parle beaucoup de choses en
ligne en virtuel etc
mais on continue d'échanger et
l'objectif de cette première phase est
d'arriver à un plan d'action que chaque
partenaire doit rédiger et qui va
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre pendant la
deuxième phase donc la deuxième phase du
projet ce n'est pas beaucoup plus
opérationnels où chaque partenaire va
s'inspirer de ce qu'il a découvert chez
d autres pour mettre en oeuvre des
projets sur son territoire et donc c'est
là on est vraiment au disons à la moitié
finalement de la première phase les
échanges d'expériences plus clair et
plus facile d'accès aussi le site
internet europe idf.fr vient d'être
rénovée par les services de la région
ile-de-france celui-ci vous permet
notamment d'en savoir plus sur les fonds
structurels européens dans la région
l'actualité de l'europe aussi en ile de
france ou encore découvrir les nouveaux
appels à projets l actualité de l'europe
et de l'union européenne c'est aussi les
nombreuses commandes de la commission
européenne auprès des sociétés
pharmaceutiques dans la perspective d'un
vaccin contre la copie 19 ou encore des
tensions sur le futur budget de l'union
européenne
regardez un sixième contrats pour des
vaccins en europe la commission
européenne vient d'annoncer un nouvel
accord avec la société pharmaceutique
moderna au total la commission
européenne a déjà précommandé près d'un
milliard et demi de doses dans la
perspective d'une campagne de
vaccination qui serait géré ensuite par
les états membres
l'institution annonce déjà négocié un 7e
comptera le coronavirus qui était aussi
au coeur des discussions des dirigeants
des états membres le 19 novembre dernier
réunis en visioconférence les vingt-sept
se sont engagés à renforcer leur
coordination pour lutter contre le virus
querelles financière et de valeur au
sommet de l'europe
la hongrie la pologne et la slovénie
s'oppose à l'adoption du budget de
relance de l'union européenne il est
hors de question pour ces pays de
conditionner le versement des fonds
européens au respect de l'état de droit
pour rappel les états membres sont
parvenus à s'entendre sur un plan de
relance communautaire de 750 milliards
d'euros cet été
somme qui s'ajoute au budget de l'union
européenne pour les six prochaines
années
de plus de 1000 milliards d'euros
contact établi avec joe biden charles
michel le président du conseil européen
s'est entretenu lundi 23 novembre par
téléphone avec le nouveau président
américain tout fraîchement élu l'ancien
ministre belge a notamment convié son
homologue à lui rendre visite l'an
prochain dans le cadre d'un sommet avec
les chefs d'état charles michel souhaite
aussi reconçu à l'alliance
transatlantique mise à mal par la
présidence de donald trump
nouvel épisode dans l'opposition entre
parlement européen de strasbourg et de
bruxelles
inquiet de la somme envisagée 500
millions d'euros pour la rénovation du
parlement situé dans la capitale belge
de nombreux élus alsaciens ont signé une
lettre destinée à alerter le président
du parlement européen david sassoli sur
le sujet pour ces élus de tels travaux
sont injustifiées en pleine crise
économique et sociale
les élus de l'est de la france s'insurge
aussi contre l'annulation répétées des
sessions plénières normalement prévue à
strasbourg depuis le début de l'épidémie
de lakovic 19 en mars dernier est un
autre sujet d'actualité parfois oublié
ces dernières semaines les négociations
encore en cours entre britanniques et
européens pour établir une nouvelle
relation entre les deux parties
officiellement la période de transition
débuté en janvier dernier doit se
terminer le 31 décembre prochain
qu'elles sont encore les points de
blocage le risque d'une odile est il
vraiment ou pas du tout écarté nous
avons posé ces questions et d'autres à
emmanuel saulnier acacias enseignante à
lui vs cul et spécialiste du sujet
[Musique]
les négociations ont repris contre toute
attente boris johnson ayant souhaité y
mettre un terme initialement le 15
octobre dernier puisque ça aurait dû
être la fin des négociations alors
l'occasion d'un conseil européen
mais voilà dans l'hypothèse de assez
dramatique d'un odile des négociations
ont finalement repris cette semaine il y
a des points du bol de blocage très
précis qui sont en réalité les mêmes
depuis des mois le point le plus
saillant et
la pêche parce que ça concerne aussi
bien l'union européenne que le royaume
uni peut-être même encore plus l'union
européenne que le royaume uni est encore
plus la france que les autres étant donc
là il ya des négociations difficiles sur
la question de l'accord trouvé sur la
pêche mais aussi sur des points plus
techniques en matière de concurrence en
matière dette d'états en matière de
réciprocité j'allais dire de confiance
ce qu'on appelle le level playing field
où il y a encore une incompréhension
entre les deux parties il y a un
problème de calendrier dans la mesure où
sur le plan procédural
en effet il faut une fois que l'accord
sera conclu
l'approbation par le parlement européen
par le conseil et que ensuite par
l'ensemble des états membres de l'union
européenne puisque c'est un accord mixte
donc là on est vraiment dans un délai
extrêmement serré si on n'arrive pas à
quelque chose ce week-end on ne pourra
pas au 31 décembre avoir une entrée en
vigueur d'un quelconque accord au 1er
janvier mais on peut imaginer d'autres
choses un accord moins ambitieux très
partiel et qui renvoient à des
négociations ultérieures ce qui de fait
pourrait prolonger
contrairement à ce que boris johnson
avait dit peut-être des négociations sur
l'année 2000 21 mai à ce jour là
personne ne peut prédire l'avenir
on sait qu'un accord pourrait être signé
lors des derniers jours du mois de
décembre en convoquant un conseil
européen extraordinaire le 28 décembre a
été envisagée mais voilà aujourd'hui
personne ne peut le savoir à part les
négociateurs eux-même et éventuellement
le no deal a été envisagée aux deux
étapes de la négociation c'est à dire
dans un premier temps l'accord dit de
retrait on a cru qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'accord de retrait on envisageait déjà
un odile ce qui était quelque chose
d'assez dramatique puisque le sceau de
la falaise c'est à dire le basculement
au statut d'états tiers n'aurait pas du
tout été prévu là c'est une autre
perspective c'est à dire c'est sur
l'application des règles européennes qui
sont actuellement en vigueur et le
basculement éventuel s'il n'y avait pas
d'accord sur les règles internationales
en particulier du commerce est donc un
odile ça voudrait dire basculer sur les
règles du commerce international de l'om
s'est en particulier
quant à virus n'est responsable de rien
la seule responsabilité ou le seul
impact que ça peut avoir c'est sur
l'économie britannique économie mondiale
évidemment mais l'économie britannique
en particulier d'où la baisse de
popularité très importante du premier
ministre boris johnson puisque les
effets conjugués de la coved plus
supposée du bric site à venir qu'il y
ait accord ou non à cordes ailleurs il
coûts supplémentaires que ça va
engendrer le risque d'entraîner la
vraiment avec une très grande certitude
un marasme économique
au moins pour les prochains mois elle
voit à prochaines années c'est un
chiffre est un constat déjà établi
depuis de nombreuses années les
principaux médias français boudent
l'actualité de l'union européenne selon
une récente étude de la fondation jean
jaurès et de lina seulement 3 % du temps
d'antenne des grandes radios et chaînes
de télévision est consacré à l'actualité
de l'europe c'est pour alerter sur ce
sujet et ce constat que plusieurs
personnalités élus journalistes mais
aussi représentants de la société civile
ont co signé récemment une tribune dans
la presse
il demande notamment au csa et à l'état
de se saisir du sujet véronique auger
vous êtes la présidente de l'association
des journalistes européens
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé pour lancer
cette tribune dont vous êtes la co
initiatrice et est-ce qu'il ya un moment
déclencheur particulier ce qui a
déclenché la tribune
en fait c'est que au mois de septembre
il ya eu le discours sur l'état de
l'union de la présidente de la
commission européenne
et qui a été un discours mais vraiment
fondateur sur sur les années à venir
surtout ce qui était changement
climatique tout ce qui était changement
numérique la 5g le camp olemps l'état de
droit c'est vraiment quelque chose que
les gens de près connaître parce que
c'est leur avenir qui en dépend et il ya
eu aucune diffusion en direct de ce
discours sur les toutes infos dans les
journaux télé du soir est également dans
un grand nombre de radios à tout mais un
grand nombre de radios ça fait même un à
offre donc ça ça vraiment s'amuser ça
nous a mis en pétard avec l'association
des journalistes européens et pas
seulement et quand le mouvement européen
france nous a proposé de de co écrire
cette tribune et d'un monde
on a dit oui qu'est ce qui explique
d'après vous at elle des intéressements
de la part des principaux médias
français est en fait les rédacteurs en
chef part du principe que c'est
compliqué donc qu'il faut réexpliquer
systématiquement et que souvent il n'y a
pas d'image donc à la télé on se dit ouh
là là c'est encore plus compliqué d'en
parler et donc ils n'en parlent pas et
c'est là où moi je dis ils n'ont pas
complètement tort mais il faudrait donc
tout ce qui est institutionnel opn soit
soient plus claires s'exprime mieux face
- d'informations mais la fasse mieux
et puis il faudrait qu'à l'école on
apprenne le béaba de commentcamarche là
alors on comprend bien au delà des de
l'éducation des plus jeunes mais aussi
des étudiants en école de journalisme
vous demandez aussi et c'est à l'état de
prendre les choses en main qu'est ce qui
ne pourrait faire concrètement quels
sont vos recommandations
d'abord déjà nous souhaiterions que le
csa jobs comme il l'a fait par exemple
pour la visibilité des femmes à
l'antenne la visibilité des dom tom la
visibilité des handicapés nous
considérons que le csa peut
signé une charte avec les télévisions
notamment publics et les radios pour qu'
il n'y ait plus d'europe à l'antenne
après oui on a parlé d'un espace de
coworking qui a fait un peu de bruit et
à bruxelles parce que au début on
s'était mal exprimée dans la lettre que
on avait publié et il croyait que
c'était en réalité pour ceux qui sont
déjà correspondant à bruxelles
non l'idée qu'on avait c'était plutôt
pour toutes les rédactions qui ont ils
n'ont pas l'argent pour envoyer des
équipes ou ou des cdd des journalistes
pour aller enquêter en profondeur à
bruxelles sur l'ailé sur des sujets
précis qui n'ont pas cet argent de
pouvoir les pousser à à le faire et il y
aurait une sorte de death passe dans
lequel il trouverait à la fois belle et
les outils pour travailler dans le calme
et également des possibilités de faire
des rencontres avec des lobbys des
experts des gens de la commission etc
merci véronique aux médias pour toutes
ces précisions et pour avoir répondu à
nos questions tv 78 espère à travers ce
magazine européen de travail et une
meilleure couverture médiatique de
l'europe et nous ne sommes pas les seuls
d'ailleurs dans les yvelines à le faire
puisque radio sensations a aussi son
magazine européen magazine bimensuel il
s'appelle zone europe
le prochain numéro sera diffusé ce
samedi 28 novembre à 19 heures le
journaliste corentin alonso interrogera
notamment l'eurodéputé et bernard guetta
sur des sujets d'actualité qui sont la
liberté d'expression et les droits de
l'homme regarder et une procédure une
procédure qui a été déclenchée par la
commission européenne en décembre 2017
pour risques de violation grave des
valeurs de l'union européenne ou est-ce
que ça on est cette procédure est est ce
qu'elle peut aboutir sur quelque chose
donc pour l'instant elle n'a pas
beaucoup
e
fait progresser les choses mais
simplement elle pose un problème
politique au régime qui sont concernés
parce que c'est quand même pas très
agréable pour eux d'être montrés du
doigt et accusés de viol et l'état de
droit ou plus précisément en pologne par
exemple de viol et l'indépendance de la
justice
c'est la fin de ce set 8 europe vous
pouvez retrouver comme d'habitude tous
ces modules reportage sur notre site tv
78 points comme sur les réseaux sociaux
de la chaîne si on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8 europe fin
décembre à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le